You're father of ten
children,
ages two to 31 and a grandbaby,
a year and a half.
What is it about being
a father--
I'm not--
not even that you love,
how did the experience
of becoming a father
multiple times
change you as a man,
as a human?
Wow, that's too much to say.
Well, just give me a little
bit of that.
- Give me a little bit.
- Yeah, I will say that, uh,
my children are the center
of my life.
And having children
and having family,
it keeps you grounded
and centered.
If you put your children first,
before you make any decision,
you'll never make
a bad decision.
- Mm. That's brilliant.
- Never. You never make one
bad decision
- if you put them first.
- So is that what you were doing
those years you were resting
on the couch?
- Is that what you were doing?
- That's what I've been--
that's what I've been doing--
that's what I've been doing
since I had them.
Putting them first.
They've been first, you know?
- Yeah. That's so powerful.
- They're first.
Somebody said to me--
I was talking to somebody
last week and they were like--
what did they say? It was like,
"So this movie 'Coming 2
America.'
This is your legacy.
And your legacy--"
And I was like, "My legacy?
My legacy is not movies.
My legacy is my children.
Not my-- my movies."
When I die, ain't nobody gonna
be at my funeral
standing over the coffin going,
"Then first he did '48 Hours,'
then he moved on to
'Trading Places.'
And the he did the great
'Beverly Hills Cop.'
Let's show a clip.